Цей червоноклоп або москаликвийшов із зимової сплячки
не в березні, а в середині лютого.
Попрокидалися і сонечка.
Активізувалися й дощові черв’яки.
Первоцвіти цього року б’ють рекорди раннього цвітіння в умовах повної відсутності снігу.
Бруньки на деревах подекуди
теж набухли ще у лютому.
Якщо в березні серйозно похолодає, як прогнозують українські метеорологи,
квіти та дерева можуть залишитися без запилення і плодів,
оскільки загинуть багато комах.
Кліматична криза крокує планетою, і Україна не стала винятком,
сповна відчуваючи на собі зміни клімату, каже кліматологиня Світлана Краковська.
Те, що Україну очікує відсутність кліматичної зими, як цього року
вчена разом з іншими українськими колегами прогнозувала ще в2014році.
Кліматична система змінилася
і нам слід готуватися до того, що зима залишилася в минулому.
На жаль, все відбувається досить швидко.
В нас буде значно теплішати грудень.
Що він не буде практично зимовим місяцем.
Ми це бачимо наразі також.
І було зроблено також прогноз, що може бути
холоднішими березень, і ми теж бачимо в минулі роки.
Цей документ є шостим національним повідомленням науковців
про зміни клімату в Україні до2030-го і2050-го років.
Українські науковці підготували його в рамках членства
в організації з питань зміни клімату ООН.
Вони застерігають: в Україні в ці періоди може зникнути
і звичайна зима, і звичне для нас літо.
Відповідно, з огляду на прогнози у Карпатах, наприклад,
не варто будувати нові гірськолижні курорти.
А на узбережжях Азовського та Чорного морів традиційний курортний сезон влітку
через страшенну спеку теж відійде в минуле.
Взагалі спека стане великою проблемою для усіх регіонів.
Тож приказку"готуй санчата влітку" доведеться перефразувати
на"готуй кондиціонери взимку".
В Україні багато досить ознак зміни клімату
на які, можливо, хтось не звертає уваги.
Це і збільшення посушливості, причому
не тільки в південних, а і в північних регіонах.
Тобто зменшення води в колодязях,
зменшення водності річок
у тих регіонах, які ніколи не потерпали від посухи.
Це, з іншого боку, збільшення
інтенсивності зливових опадів.
Ми вже маємо досить мало опадів фронтальних,
коли декілька днів малесенькі дощики
промочують дуже добре ґрунт,
скоріше це виливається в одній зливі, яка може змити цей ґрунт.
Побільшає опадів у вигляді граду, очікує кліматологиня.
Почастішають смерчі та торнадо, і не лише на півдні.
В різних регіонах України кліматичні зміни виглядатимуть по-різному.
Але адаптувати під зміни клімату
доведеться цілі галузі економіки.
І в першу чергу - енергетичну.
Відомствам вже зараз слід замислитися,
як отримати зиск від зменшення споживання енергоресурсів
для опалення взимку.
І при цьому уникнути відключення електроенергії влітку,
коли усі увімкнуть кондиціонери, каже вчена.
Якщо ми трансформуємо свою енергетику,
ми відмовляємося від вугілля.
І це має бути табу для України.
Насправді для цього є приклади в світі,
ми можемо наслідувати ці приклади.
І людей ми можемо переорієнтувати на інше -
на виробництво тих самих сонячних панелей, які зараз набагато здешевіли.
Альтернативні джерела енергії в майбутньому
можуть поступово замінити той же газ.
Доти Україні слід багато зробити,
аби врятувати від руйнувань сильними вітрами, повенями
та високими температурами не лише сотні кілометрів газогонів,
а фактично усю інфраструктуру, зведену за старими будівельними нормами,
які не передбачають впливу кліматичних змін.
Почасти нові кліматичні вимоги в будівництві
вже починають з’являтися в законах України.
Звісно, від зміни клімату можна отримати і зиск.
Аграрії, приміром, можуть збирати подвійні та навіть потрійні врожаї.
Щоправда, їх доведеться захищати від екзотичних шкідників,
які прийдуть на українську територію разом з посухою.
Також слід буде відмовитися від традиційних сортів пшениці
а кукурудзи і перейти на більш пристосовані до спеки.
Голова Національного антарктичного центру Євген Дикий
щороку разом з колегами аналізує прискорення наслідків змін клімату в Антарктиді,
де стає дедалі тепліше і дедалі швидше тануть льодовики.
Вчений впевнений, що Україна в майбутньому може перетворитися на пустелю,
якщо вже зараз в містах не почнуть висаджувати більше трави та дерев,
а в полях не почнуть терміново вживати заходів з порятунку чорноземів.
В насі зараз видуває кожного року більше чорноземів,
ніж багато країн мають взагалі.
Швидше за все треба готуватися: А - до збереження ґрунтів,
Б - переходити від поливу такого, коли вода в надлишку
до таких методів, як в Ізраїлі,
коли капілярний полив - кожна рослина окремо.
Дороге обладнання, дорогі трубочки. Але вода скоро стане дорожчою.
Україна насправді не має великого запасу якісної питної води.
Євген Дикий закликає владу вже зараз вживати заходів
щодо більш економного споживання.
0% населення України отримують воду з Дніпра.
Стан річки незадовільний.
Враховуючи те, що до2020року в Україні побільшає не лише весняних,
а і літніх повеней, вода буде дедалі бруднішою,
тож про стратегічні запаси питної води
необхідно дбати вже зараз, застерігає науковець.
Якість повітря через збільшення періодів, коли будуть
сильні вітри з пилом з полів, буде погіршуватися.
В ідеалі Україні вже зараз треба чистити повітря в містах,
як це, приміром, роблять у Німеччині за допомогою ось таких установок.
Більше пилу в повітрі і вищі температури, ймовірно,
зумовлять збільшення випадків захворювань органів дихання,
серцево-судинної системи,
появи різних раніше нетипових для України вірусів та інфекцій тощо.
Світлана Краковська зізнається, що останні два роки
майже щотижня виступає з лекціями перед різними аудиторіями,
аби якось підготувати людей до майбутніх змін, навчити їх того,
що кожен може стати рятівникомпланети, яка задихається у кількості сміття -
не лише побутового, а і промислового.
У нас зараз життя зайвих речей.
Наприклад, пакування займає в цьому смітті 25-30%.
Це дуже багато і це там, де що ми можемо заощадити.
Вода, повітря,
енергія , електрика ми маємо використовувати відповідально.
Ми можемо використовувати повторно щось.
Якщо хтось щось не потребує, може віддати іншому.
І це буде також заощадження енергії на виробництво.
Вчена тішиться, що за останні кілька років в Україні побільшало людей,
які переймаються зміною клімату,
відмовляються від пластикових пакетів,  збирають і сортують сміття.
Проте завдання, яке стоїть перед усіма державами, набагато серйозніше.
Україна, за словами кліматологині, чимало зробила на шляху
зменшення утворення різних викидів, зокрема, парникових.
. З 90- их років - на 60%.
І хоча не усі уряди приділяли увагу питанню
адаптації до кліматичних змін, останнім часом ця проблема,
за спостереженнями опитанихDWекспертів,
активніше обговорюється в урядових кабінетах.
У різних містах України місцева влада ініціює
висаджування великої кількості дерев.
Адже загрозливих повідомлень вже багато.
Ліси та торф’яники щороку потерпають від пожеж.
Цього року вже констатовано, що через відсутність снігу взимку
відбулося різке обміління річок.
Аграрії не виключають, що буде зібрано
як мінімум на 20% менше врожаю зернових.
Світлана Краковська впевнена, що Україні конче необхідно
створити окремий Центр кліматичних змін за участіфахівців
з питань адаптації до зміни клімату.
А ще - відроджувати систему єдиної служби Гідрометцентру
та збільшувати держзамовлення на навчання метеорологів нового покоління.